oh that's hypnosis today we're gonna get
hypnotized to figure out past life that
we may have experienced and they nervous
I have never been hypnotized because I
like to be in control of myself at all
times I'm scared of like being exposed
and it doesn't mean like necessarily
just like physically naked I've been
practicing past life regression therapy
for over 700 years today we are going to
see three different examples of past
life regression therapy this is when a
person chooses an issue that he or she
would like to overcome then we travel
back to who the person was the past life
to the event or events that are going to
illuminate the cause of the issue and
from there were able to him so choice do
you mind having the hypno cat on your
lap no I completely enjoy it what is
your intention for having your past life
aggression I want to heal my migraines
for it today I would like to focus on my
fear of waves and water is there
something in your life you'd like to
heal it's it's doubt its doubt so the
induction is to go from a full waking
state down into the hypnotic trance I
thought you're doing it to me already
alright I'm I am now I am going to show
you how powerful you are Joyce you're so
powerful that you can relax your eyelids
wonderfully totally and completely for
the subconscious mind knows how to
generate healing your power word is the
word trust because you can trust
yourself more and more you are now in an
alpha state of hypnosis and we can now
hack into the subconscious mind you can
imagine or visualize getting called to
anim
in corridor and you're gliding through
three step into the light to step into
the light one step into the light at
zero take a big step forward you are in
another time in another place and now
look down at your hand or you a man or a
woman a boy or a girl woman and look at
your palms and your fingertips
are you a girl of leisure or do you work
hard with your hands jewelry on now tell
me about the jewelry describe it they
like teeth like alligator teeth yes
describe the landscape the environment
it's like a swamp like high grass travel
to your home in your past life what does
your home look like small the
countryside and look around and orient
yourself do you know and what land you
live skull what can you see I mean like
Canyon and ru or low or there are other
people there's other men and women men
only I think it's just men yes do you
know your name or is someone calling to
you even a nickname
I heard Alice yes speak your name out
loud though tell me about your home
that's good it's like alligator people
that alligator means a lot for us see if
there's anything that you carry
I have like a tiny bag with me you have
kids
boys girl boys how many years to tell me
about your home don't think we can go
home I shouldn't have left - no of
course not why shouldn't you have left
two people were with aren't good
let the amazing wisdom of the
subconscious mind pull you towards the
event that will illuminate and resolve
your ambivalence about the ocean what is
happening anima you can't stay here
anymore no of course not why do you have
to leave we go into the water
I love there in my hair and what's
happening I'm pushing your boat into the
water and I'm trying to go what they
pull me back let me leave who's not
gonna let you leave voices the other
side though let me leave what happened
with the ocean take a nice deep breath
and release any shame associated with it
I think for sure I drowned in there but
it was by accident I think I went in
looking for something so tell me what
you see
and be brain and left yeah you left and
who did you leave behind I think I left
everyone did you go by yourself did you
take the boys it's ok because this was
not a good place for you what finally
happened what happened yeah
you're at the moment after death and you
are going to go up higher and higher
until you connect with every incarnation
from all your past lives you may ask the
question how am I able to release the
trauma of wanting to go but having to
stay we're going to go just the moment
after death you are there how did you
die
Alice I just am on the floor something
just gave out huh and where did you feel
it in your body before it happened you
can remember my heart yeah look at my
finger with your eyes closed look even
more with your wisdom you can enjoy the
ocean what insight or perspective does
the wise self reveal to you speak it out
loud there wasn't really a choice and
really listen to your wise self can you
allow yourself to forgive yourself and
give me an honest answer I thought
they'd be fine when you were Alice you
didn't have control freedom or power
breathe an and and acknowledge and now
ask as a daughter of the 21st century is
being held back still serving you and if
it's not take a very very very deep
breath and release being held back now
I'm gonna ask you a question as Kate do
you have power freedom and choice yes
you have power freedom and choice and
one two three four five choice eyes open
wide away one two three or four
comfortable
it was strange I was like her at first
and then I like became this alligator
damn I didn't want to say anything I was
so like ashamed of everything I was
saying of course yeah but your Y self
told you you didn't have a choice under
those circumstances yeah would you trust
me that it
stands on its own as what has happened
to women for generation who truly had no
choice it taught me a lot I usually get
a headache around once a day but today I
just feel really calm no chill I have to
figure out what I feel about all of this
if it's a way for us to like
personifying our underlying guilt from
other situations or if I actually
believe in past lives
it was interesting just because like I'm
with both super spiritual and at the
same time I try to be as logical as
possible and I'm just like Oh what was
real and what was me it kind of doesn't
matter like it was just a really good
experience to like just let your mind
flow exactly the way that it wants to
[Music]